ken Ackerman what got you interested in
writing a book about James Garfield you
know I had a feeling you would start
with that Garfield is one of those
presidents who gets ignored by most
historians if you do a search on Google
or any of the other search engines and
you type in Garfield they'll get a lot
more hits on the cartoon cat than you
will on the former president what got me
started on him was this I the the the
idea for this book flashed in my mind
watching the presidential campaign of
1996 and watching the conventions that
year that was the year of Dole versus
Clinton the conventions that year were
totally staged they were scripted
nothing interested have interesting
happen the networks that year talked
about not covering them at all but for
the final speeches and I thought at the
time wouldn't it be good to write a book
about a political convention when they
really mattered when they were
passionate exciting bare-knuckle
contests unpredictable
fights and I started looking for a good
one to write about and I came up with
1880 which was Garfield you put that
together with the Garfield assassination
one of the more misunderstood events in
history in American history and the fact
that there was a line of causation
between the convention and the shooting
of the president to me made a compelling
story for a book what was the line the
line was this the convention the
politics of that at that time the Gilded
Age after the Civil War was very much
dominated by factional contests broad
power struggles very similar to what was
going on in the business world very
similar to what was going on on the
western frontier at that time the big
fight was between two groups in the
Republican Party called the stall words
and the half-breeds
Garf Garfield got stuck in the middle of
that fight he got stuck between the two
sides
his nomination came after a 36 ballot
deadlock because the two sides were
having a very strenuous tug-of-war that
year and he got caught in the middle
that's what eventually got him killed
James Garfield in 1880 was how old he
was 48 years old what was he doing he
was a congressman
he was a kind of a career congressman he
had been in Washington for 16 years
serving in the House of Representatives
he had been the Republican leader he had
been chairman of several committees he
was one of the up-and-coming members of
the Republican Party he was also a civil
war veteran and that made him a very
popular figure and where did he live he
lived he had a house on I Street here in
Washington he was from Ohio he had a
farm that he had bought a few years ago
in Mentor Ohio just outside of Cleveland
who was Charles Guiteau Charles Guiteau
is the man who pulls the trigger that of
the gun that kills Garfield he is the
assassin he at the time in 1880 was
about 39 years old somewhat younger he
was living in Boston Massachusetts
selling insurance so as I read your book
I kept saying to myself I'd have no idea
because I haven't read all the graphic
books this is what's different about
this book Charles Guiteau makes his
entrance about page 134 mm-hmm why so
early and there's a thread that runs all
the way through the book is that new is
that a new idea that you had well what's
what I tried to do that was a little
different than other Garfield books was
to show that the assess the
assassination of the president was not
simply the result of a disappointed
office seeker who took out his anger on
the president Charles Guiteau well he
may have in fact been insane was someone
who was very caught up in the political
process he was he was identified
actually with one of the major factions
he worked with the straw words he
considered himself a stalwart he went to
New York at the beginning of the
campaign and became chummy with the
people he hung out at the headquarters
he gave a couple of speeches even though
the leaders of the party of the Stallard
branch people like General Grant and
Roscoe Conkling the leaders even though
they considered him very minor he
considered himself very major and what
happened to him was very much wrapped up
with the larger politics of the era
Guiteau was from where he was from
Freeport Illinois what did he do in his
life
the age 39 well he was a shiftless
shifting character he he never held any
job very long when he was very young he
was brought up by a very strict father
father luther Guto who is who had very
strong religious beliefs he was sent to
the Oneida community in upstate New York
which was one of the utopian communities
at the time they believed in and free
love and shared labor they had as a
socialist ethic he didn't fit in very
well there he didn't get along with the
other people when he left he actually
sued them at one point for 4 wages he
wrote some religious tracts and tried to
sell them but never very successfully he
worked as a lawyer he worked as a bill
collector he worked he tried to start a
newspaper at one point but couldn't get
funding for it he was married for a few
years but his marriage ended up in
divorce because he beat his wife he
never had much money he was always a
step or two ahead of the bill collectors
well go back to you you talked about it
he was a member of the stalwart faction
where were the stalwarts located well
geographically they were all over the
country they were but the the Stahl
words were the group of within the
Republican Party there were two factions
and they went back to the time of
General Grant when President when
General Grant was the president the
stalwarts were the Republicans who were
the most loyal to Grant and that's how
they define themselves they were the the
hardline true believers in General Grant
and in a way the Radical Republicans of
the Reconstruction era evolved into the
stall words of the post-reconstruction
era would they get the name this that I
don't know that but they were the the
true believers they were the hardcore
and that's all it meant is it I thought
you were stalwart you love grant you
loved grant it was not there was very
little ideological here and this was the
the difference between them was became
very much factional personality driven
and if you're a half-breed what did that
mean half-breed that word came from the
same era it started out as an insult
the people who weren't very strong
toward grant were considered half-breeds
it was it was there was the way you
would refer to someone almost as a
traitor that they weren't strong enough
in their in their support of the team
all Republican they were all Republican
this is all within the Republican Party
after a while though when when the grant
administration became tarnished with
scandal and grants reputation fell the
half-breeds they started to view that
name as a compliment
they included a number of reformers at
first but over time they simply became
the opposite side of the straw words
they were led by two very strong
personalities the Stahl words by General
Grant and increasingly by a group of
Senate bosses primarily Roscoe Conkling
the the half-breed side was taken over
by James G Blaine who was their leader
in 1880 was he like plain is an
interesting character he is probably the
most like a modern politician a very
smart man a very charming man he was the
Speaker of the House of Representatives
for about a dozen years and that was
where he made his national reputation he
was a newspaper writer in Maine he was
one of a number of newspaperman at the
time who went into politics and made
that their base he's someone who when he
came into a room you would know
everyone's name he would have a joke to
say to everyone he got old he had very
good people skills he his politics were
similar to the stalwarts in the sense
that they all believed in civil rights
for the south a protective tariff for
industry those kinds of things but
Blaine was part of the progressive wing
of the party in the sense that he
reached out to the younger voters to the
western frontier to the north and he
rubbed the wrong way with with some of
the grant supporters so you also had
Roscoe Conkling that you mentioned and
what was he all about Roscoe Conkling
was one of the real personalities of the
era in a way that someone asked me when
they read this book is there is there
not a Roscoe Conkling
in the country and my response was there
really ought to be Roscoe Conkling was
the senator from New York State he was
the leader of the Stallard wing he was
the leading senator in the sense that
they didn't have a majority leader of
the Senate at that point as a formal
physician but he really filled it he was
the most talkative person on the Senate
floor he was a very vain arrogant
strong-willed opinionated person he was
a brilliant orator he was a a credible
candidate for president in 1876 he was
very close personally with Grant and
after awhile he devoted his strength of
personality to building up the machine
in New York State James Garfield the
last man to go from the United States
House of Representatives to the
presidency correct now no one since then
no one since then and you by the way
teaches all along in your footnotes a
lot about the history of what's happened
over in the Senate did you in the house
did you do that on purpose I mean it was
that oh yes I was trying to show how
things were different than verses now
particularly this the Senate is much
different than than it than it is today
in the sense that the the the US Senate
in 1880 conducted a lot of its business
in secret private sessions its members
were elected by state legislatures
rather than voters as a result it was a
much less accountable body it was much
more swayed by strong personalities by
it was much much cleverer than it is
today even though it still has that
reputation another point you make it
goes all the way from that time to the
year 2001 was the closeness of the
Senate after the election of 1880 yes
that was something that was very
striking the year 2000
two years ago was the first Senate tie
since 1880 and it was the first time
that the Senate had flipped mid-year
when senator Jeffords changed parties
and went from being a Republican to an
independent and shifted the Senate
control two years ago that was the first
time that that had happened since in
fact the Garfield assassinate
changed it in 1881 you mentioned about
the closed-door sessions and you also
have another foot another says up until
1929 yes what happened what was what
were the rules in the Senate up until
1929 the rules were that for nominations
specifically and for treaties
specifically these would be handled in
what was called executive session an
executive session was essentially a
secret session of the Senate it was not
reflected in the congressional record or
the formal records of the Senate the
public was kept out the doors were
closed and that's where the voting took
place that's where the debates took
place did you know how people voted only
through gossip the newspapers would go
and track down senators and ask them
what had happened and some senators
would talk about it
but there was no formal way to know so
all cabinet nominations all Supreme
Court justices anybody that was
nominated by the president the public
would not see the debate here the debate
be able to sit in there the press
couldn't report it and you didn't know
how the votes were that's correct and
also there were no public hearings for
even cabinet members let alone judges if
they're to the extent that there were
hearings they were generally behind
closed doors and often there were no
hearings at all so what changed in 1929
I don't know exactly what changed in
1929 but that is when the rule was
changed let me read a paragraph in yours
this is early in the book on page 15
today you can search the congressional
record and globe through two hundred
years of debate and never see a member
of Congress insult a colleague so
directly brutally and articulately on
the record in public looking directly at
him across the room as Blaine did to
Conkling that day it was one of the best
beaches of Blaine's life utterly
spontaneous memorably colorful and full
family destructive what was the day this
was the day in 1866 when James Blaine
and Roscoe Conkling had a real dust-up
in the House of Representatives which
caused a lifelong feud between the two
men a bitter lifelong feud between the
two men it started over an argument
about whether the way
to take away the job of an obscure
military bureaucrat in the course of it
Conkling used language which blamed
perceived as calling him a liar and
possibly threatening him to a duel at
the end of it this took place over two
or three days but in the end of the
final day of it
Blaine took the floor read a long letter
that accused Conklin virtually of fraud
of taking double payments from the
government
Conklin responded with a very arrogant
dismissive gesture towards Blaine Blaine
came back and gave a a two paragraph
speech spontaneously extemporaneously
where he refused to concur if you refer
to Conkling and his grand eloquent
turkey gobbler strut his arrogance he he
used classical allusions in it he
referred to to Hercules and Thirsty's
and at the end of it the two men would
never talk to each other for virtually
the rest of their lives and they were
all Republicans these were all
Republicans this was all intramural
within the Republican Party and it's
interesting because it did unfold over
several days that had occurred to me at
least that at an elder Republican had
set the two of them down this is when
the two of them were still young they
were in their 30s if someone had set
them down and said cool it you're on the
same side bury the hatchet they probably
would have done it but instead this got
out of control and went on from there
what have you done in your life that got
to the point where you would even
understand all the stuff well I worked
on Capitol Hill for a lot of years I
worked I did two long stints on Capitol
Hill I worked for Senator Charles Percy
in the late 1970's and early 1980s as a
council on the governmental affairs
committee Chicago Republican Chicago
Republican and then more recently for
Senator Patrick Leahy of Vermont
Democrat Vermont Democrats I've worked
on both sides for a Republican and for
Democrats and did you work for Dan
Glickman if they Agriculture Department
yes I was the administrator of the risk
management agency which oversees the
federal crop insurance program I did
that for seven years both under Dan
Glickman and under Mike espy who were
the secretaries at the time and what are
you doing now
I'm a lawyer in Washington DC I work at
a law firm called Olson Frank and we de
that specializes in agriculture food and
drug medical devices several other
fields and I'm more and more becoming a
writer why I enjoy it I and I enjoy I
enjoy learning I enjoy I enjoyed digging
up these old stories that no one has
found before and putting them on paper
and bringing them to light so of all the
stuff in your book mmm where did you
find the juiciest tidbit that is you
look back on what you got here in this
book that that you enjoyed the most the
juiciest tidbit uh-huh I'll give you
this one the Chester Alan Arthur papers
Chester Alan Arthur was the was
Garfield's vice president he was a
member of the opposite faction he was
part of the reason Garfield was killed
Garfield was killed to put to put Arthur
in the White House when the toe pulled
the trigger he said I am a stalwart and
Arthur will be president for some time
Arthur had to live with that onus
because people suspected that he may
have had something to do with it even
though there's no evidence that he did
Arthur was a very vain man in the sense
that he was a clothes horse he dressed
well he ate well he lived in a a
beautiful brown brownstone home on
Lexington Avenue in New York City he
drank good wine he went to the best
clubs in his papers he made a point to
throw out all of the politically
interesting letters all of the sensitive
materials what he saved were his bills
from the tailor his bills from hotels
his daily to-do
the juiciest tidbit that you asked for
that I thought was and when Garfield was
getting ready to become vice president
of the United States excuse me when
Arthur was getting ready to become vice
president the way he prepared himself
was he went on a shopping binge he and
the bill is sitting in his paper he's at
the Library of Congress
he bought seven suits a new coat several
pairs of trousers several shirts got
several old suits pressed for a total of
not quite eight hundred dollars which in
modern dollars would be almost twenty
thousand any paid in cash well we're
talking about Chester Arthur who became
president states because of the
assassination he had a job in New York
appointed by which President Grant and
how long was he in the job about six or
seven years he was fired by erythro
Behe's yes why I'm suspicious well for
tolerating corruption even though no
corruption on him was ever shown and the
job was he was collector of the Port of
New York you say that he made twenty
thousand dollars back then that today
they'd be worth four hundred thousand
yes which would have been more than the
president I'd stay well today's the
president 1000 but back then he would
actually have made more than the
president I say yes why or two ways when
his fixed salary was about twelve
thousand which was more than the fixed
salary of the vice president the cabinet
the members of the Senate everyone but
the president and then in addition to
that he as the head of the office was
allowed to collect certain Commission's
or bounties the the the reason this was
such a powerful job was that something
like three-quarters to 80% of all
imports into the United States came
through New York City the port of the
collection house the Customs House is
where the tariffs were collected and
those tariffs made up the bulk of the
united states treasury of almost or I
think over a hundred million dollars a
year came in just to the new york custom
house arthur as the collector was able
to keep a certain percentage of
uncollectible that he that that took
extra work to
to nail down if they were disputed bills
for instance he was able to keep a
portion of that as his commission that
was later repealed it was something
called moieties and it was way too
repealed by Congress but if you add that
to his salary in most years he was
making more than the president and that
plays a role in the book the collector
of the Port of New York yes because why
the collector of the Port of New York
was not only the most important
financial operation outside of
Washington DC it was the most important
political appointive post in the country
really and clearly in New York State and
the reason was because it controlled the
patronage it controlled about 2,000 jobs
plus a payroll of two million dollars at
a time when party coffers were parties
collected money by making federal
employees pay a part of their salary to
the party so the collector of the Port
of New York was an extremely powerful
political position and it was very
heavily fought over Roscoe Conkling as
the New York state senator representing
the stored wing of the party insisted
that he have control of that position
Garfield when he became president after
some hesitation
after going being pulled back and forth
on this ultimately decided that he as
the president needed to control the
position and so he appointed to it a man
who was a political enemy of Conkling
who Conkling felt he had to defeat we're
obviously gonna skip an awful lot in
your book but I want to go to Charles
Guiteau no 39 years old a lawyer
Freeport Illinois Chicago Boston Oneida
New York well why does he come to New
York City is that where he goes first to
this whole business yes he comes to New
York City and in a in 1880 at the time
of the convention he's had a lot of he's
at loose ends in his wife nothing he's
ever done has really amounted to much
he's tried to do a lot of things but
he's but he's never really has nothing
has really clicked for him his marriage
had fallen apart his um none of his jobs
had really had really worked he decided
point that he'd really like to get
involved in politics so he goes to New
York City which at the time was where
the national political parties had their
national offices and he went to the
National Republican Committee excuse me
the New York State Republican Committee
which was the largest most important one
and volunteered for the campaign I want
to jump to the end and we'll come back
to this okay
when James after James Garfield was
elected president ah and what day did
Charles Guiteau shooting July 2nd of the
first year of the first year Garfield
had been president for just about four
months when he was shot and where did he
shoot he shot him in the train station
in Washington DC it was the the
Baltimore and Potomac train station
which is on the site of where the
National Gallery of Art is today what
time a dated issue it was about 9:30 in
the morning and was what kind of weapon
it was a revolver it was called an
English Bulldog it was a five-shot
revolver and you say that he had a
choice of what weapon he wanted to buy
but he chose the weapon that he shot him
was for a reason yes he katoa in a way
had delusions of grandeur about himself
and in a way they weren't unrealistic he
decided he was going to shoot the
president he was going to excuse me he
was going to remove the president and he
recognized his gun would probably end up
in a museum so when he went to buy a gun
he didn't own one at that time there
were two that he saw in the shelf one
had an ivory handle and the other had a
wooden handle and the calculation in his
mind was you know the one with the ivory
handle would look better in a museum if
I use that one to shoot the president
would it cost an extra buck that that's
what he bought you have know where that
gun is today I understand it is in the
Smithsonian but I have not seen it you
also say and I'll take us through there
you can help us take us through the
timeline but that the the couple of days
before he shot the president he went to
the jail yes for what reason he wanted
to see what the jail was like he wanted
to see where he'd be serving time did he
get to he walked all the ways out to the
jail the jail at the time was
on the side of where Robert F Kennedy
stadium is today near the Anacostia
River he walked all the ways out there
he knocked on the front door he said I'd
like to come in and look around the jail
or thought he was a was a kook thought
that he was a crank and told him to get
lost and he walked away did he end up in
that jail yes he ended up in that jail
and then once he got there how long did
he stay there he stayed there until he
was hanged and he was hanged early the
next year so less than a year you know
where he's buried
he's actually not buried he's after he
was hanged they did an autopsy on him
partly because there had been such a
huge debate over whether he was insane
or not they didn't really find anything
very interesting and his his his
skeleton his brain and I believe his
spleen were kept in a medical Museum in
the Washington area viewable by people
that want to see it I don't think it's
viewable I did double-check it is listed
as still being there but I don't think
it's on public display and I didn't go
over to try to look at it so they didn't
bury the rest of the body somewhere they
didn't bury the rest of the body was
there any doubt when he was on trial
that he was guilty of this there is no
doubt that he pulled the trigger that
shot the president go back to again he
well let me just ask you this at what
point did he make a decision that he
wanted to kill James Garfield he made
the decision he wanted to kill James
Garfield in mid-may it was the same day
or excuse me it was two days after
Roscoe Conkling resigned from the United
States Senate because of the outcome of
his his battle with Garfield over the
control of the of the Port of New York
the New York Customs House could tell
very much recognize his fate as being
tied up in the fate of these larger
political players katoa at the time was
lobbying very hard to become the
minister to to Paris for the United
States government he came to Washington
after the election and decided he wanted
a job in government he wanted a
political appointment he felt he had
worked in the campaign he gave a couple
of speeches he was close to the stall
word leaders he had met Chester Alan
Arthur several times during the campaign
he got a few recommendations and he
decided he wanted a job he actually got
as far as meeting with Garfield they
actually had a face-to-face job
interview it was a very strange one
gita' had written a speech for the
campaign he he got in to see the
president
he gave the president a copy of his
speech to look at Garfield started
reading it and as he was reading it
Gatto --get ostatic and walked out of
the room why he felt it was enough that
Garfield was reading his speech and he
didn't want to press the point and you
say it was only three pages long there
was three pages long did you read this
week oh yes and what was it like it was
it was not especially striking in the
sense of being terribly good or terribly
bad it was a it had it it was a typical
speech of the time someone repeating the
campaign slogans of the Republicans
it just wasn't it wasn't a striking
speech one way or the other
the other thing that you do around the
assassination is you paint a picture of
the openness of all these institutions
the State Department the War Department
the White House the president the first
lady and there's a scene that you you
have ghettos sitting in Lafayette Park
for what reason at this point the tow
had decided he wanted to remove the
president he was a very methodical
person he would sit in Lafayette Park
and he would truck
the president's comings and goings did
the president have Secret Service
protection there was no Secret Service
protection at the time that would not
start until about 15 16 years later the
president felt no compunctions at all
about walking the streets of Washington
himself alone at night and here you are
only 16 years after Abraham Lincoln
yes so where did you tell live to tell
it in a series of rooming houses around
Washington and mostly in the
neighborhood of what but we would today
called Metro center around 13th and 14th
Street downtown and where is that in
relationship to the White House it's
about four or five blocks from the White
House easy walking distance from the
White House and you also talk about
James Blaine who ends up being Secretary
of State yes where does he live
he lived on 15th Street and H which is
right near Lafayette Park which is right
across the street from the White House
so the scene and tell us who John Logan
was the same when Charles Guiteau goes
to John Logan's room
the first rooming house that he is in is
a house in that neighborhood John Logan
was a very senior senator from the state
of Illinois he had been in the Senate
for several years he was one of the
triumvirate of senators who had back
General Grant in the campaign he was a
stalwart senator Charles Guiteau had a
house and had a room in that house one
day he walked up to John Logan's room
John Logan had the top floor of the
house because he was a United States
Senator and could afford to afford the
nicest room in the house he wanted to
get a recommendation for him to bring to
Blaine to help him get his job he
knocked on the door no one answered and
he so he let himself in right into John
Logan's room right into his room it was
an ante room but it was that the front
room to his apartment John Logan came in
this was about 8:00 in the morning 8:30
in the morning before breakfast John
Logan was literally just putting his
clothes on he came in John Logan came to
see who came in --get oh not shy at all
started in said I he introduced himself
he showed him the speech that he wrote
about him that he gave during the
campaign he told him that he was looking
for a job he asked for a recommendation
John Logan was a very experienced
politician and he tried very hard to be
very polite
and respectful because not knowing
anything about Guto he thought you know
here's a well-meaning volunteer maybe a
little awkward not very so it was not
very socially adept but he didn't want
to be rude to him so he tried to make
conversation but basically told him to
go away would he do the next day Guto
came back the same thing happened he
asked him to sign a recommendation Logan
said no after that Logan did go to the
woman who kept the boardinghouse and
pointed Guto out one morning at
breakfast and said you know you really
ought to make you really ought to kick
him out of this house because he told
her what had happened how he had invaded
her had invaded his privacy had gone
coming to his room said you know he's
really a little off in the head you
should do something about that
why didn't Logan lock his door this was
1880 people didn't do that people
trusted each other it was a much more
open society people didn't lock the
doors of their houses people walked the
streets people trusted each other it was
a very different world you're going back
to the gun you talked about you remember
what date he bought the gun there was a
about about about two weeks before the
shooting and the shooting again was on
watch i ii and if you come back to that
James Garfield became President on what
day March 4th I believe of 1881
so he's president and he's trying to put
a cabinet together and ghetto keeps
wanting a job and that he wants to I
know there were several places he wanted
to go but that's what was the job he
really wanted a job he really wanted was
council to Paris the Paris France so
he's asked the President himself he got
in to see the President himself he got
in several times to see the president to
the White House he got to see the
president just once then he walked over
to the State Department he got in to see
Blaine he got in to see Blaine
repeatedly because State Department then
was the old executive almost perfect
in fact Blaine would hold an open
meeting several days a week that people
could come in and simply see him you
didn't need an appointment you could
simply walk in and see the Secretary of
State
andget Oh went repeatedly to those
meetings when he would see Blaine most
of the time Blaine would put him off he
would say well I'm we're waiting at the
time this was when the the battle on
Capitol Hill was going on between
Garfield and Conkling over the
collectorship in New York Blaine would
keep saying well we're not going to make
a decision about Paris France until the
deadlock in the Senate is cleared up
then once that did clear up once there
was an outcome gita' went back to Blaine
and Blaine snapped at him he raised it
at a meeting one day and Blaine said
never talked to me about the Paris
consulship again to describe when the
ghetto looked like he was short he had
short dark hair a beard
you used the word feline yes he had a
strange walk you if he walked up to you
you wouldn't hear him he would notice
I'm standing next to you but you
wouldn't have heard him walk up to you
he talked in a what's described as a
confidential nature he would he would
talk standing right next to you in kind
of a whisper he would his his when you
looked at his face his eyes are a little
bit uneven in fact when he was on trial
for murder the psychiatrists who claimed
that he was insane pointed to the way
his eyes wind up as one of as a piece of
evidence for his insanity he was he he
dressed shabbily in the sense that he
couldn't afford new clothes he didn't
have a job in Washington he didn't have
a bankroll so after a while his clothes
had rips that were never fixed several
people pointed out that he wore rubbers
instead of shoes sometimes he handles
well no like brought rubbers like you
were in rain yeah like you're wearing
the rainstorm to keep your feet dry but
very thin and this was he came to
Washington and many of these meetings
were in March in a year when when there
was snow on the ground so we were very
thin clothes he didn't he didn't keep up
his wardrobe very well and that was very
much noticed say he met mrs. Garfield
and also was concerned when she got real
sick yes he went to a reception at the
White House which were receptions were
open to everyone you could just go and
get online and shake hands with the
president and the first lady you didn't
have to go through security it was not a
problem and at this point most of the
most of the ushers at the White House
who acted as guards to the extent they
needed guards they all knew who gita'
was he had been around several times
waiting to see if there was any news on
his job he was always trying to get in
to push his application so they all knew
who he was and it was very common for
some for a job hunter in fact when you
think about it it's a very logical thing
to do if you're a job hunter to go to
the White House to go to a reception to
make a point to meet the first lady to
try to put in a good word about yourself
and this is what he did
he met the first lady early on in the
administration he walked right up to her
shook her hand
said I'm one of the men who made your
husband the president they had a nice
talk she didn't think twice about it and
then she went on to talk to the next
person on line the beot there one of the
odd things about Guto was that he never
had anything personal against the
president he said he liked him as a man
he liked his wife when he met her there
was one of the early times when he when
he thought of when he followed them with
a gun thinking about shooting them was
as you mentioned mrs. Garfield had a
very bad case of typhoid or pneumonia no
one's quite sure what it was but a very
bad fever during the spring when when
Garfield was president and her she
really came within an inch of losing her
life afterwards Garfield took her to the
ocean to help her recuperate gita'
followed them to the train station that
morning with the thought of maybe
shooting the president that day but when
he saw them getting on the train and he
saw how mrs. Garfield was clinging to
his arm and how she looked very frail
and very sick he basically felt sorry
for her and didn't want to shoot the
president that day by the way when he
left a train station with his wife to go
to New Jersey that's an important trip
where
where did they go they went to Elberon
yes Elberon New Jersey which is
basically on the Jersey Shore it's the
northernmost point that was a very
stylish resort at the time because it
was just a narrow long boat ride from
New York City who else was there at the
time General Grant was there as well and
General Grant was in the cottage just
across the street a General Grant wanted
to win his third term and get in this
whole process what did he think of James
Garfield
um General Grant plays a very
interesting role in this General Grant
was not on good terms with Garfield he
very much wanted to win a third term in
1880 he felt that and more than he let
on
Grant was very known for for for not
sharing his feelings for having a
movable features those words are used
with them a lot not being very
expressive but in 1880 he wanted to be
president people close to him noticed
how anxious he got around the time of
the convention how he was counting the
delegates how he was following the
telegraph the news coming in on the
telegraph after the convention was over
and his backers failed to win it for him
after this 36th ballot tug of war he was
very bitter and he lets some friends
know it he was disappointed in Garfield
because Garfield didn't pay attention to
him when he went to see him and asked
for patronage for friends of his or made
recommendations or said you said you
should support this person over that
person grant was very close to Roscoe
Conkling Conkling had been very loyal to
grant over the years and so when when
Garfield and Conkling had their
falling-out grant took Conkling side and
after that the feelings between the two
of them were very tense go back to the
New Jersey stop by the way did you go to
Alderaan to see the any of the houses up
there no I did not I've been to the
Jersey Shore but not to that spot they
exist still do this I think some of
those mansions do still exist but the
but since then the more stylish New York
retreats have moved out to the Hamptons
and to Tyrone
so what are we in the month of June June
we're in June and there he gets
assassinated or shot in July yeah by the
way we're we're on it once he was shot
how long did he live he lived 79 days
and where was he during those 79 days
for most of the time he was in the white
house they actually turned a room an
upstairs room in the white house into a
sick room for him where the doctors took
care of him or arguably where the
doctors killed him but where they
treated him and then for the last few
days he was in Elberon New Jersey at the
ocean why there it was felt both by the
doctors and by Garfield and his family
that the atmosphere in Washington during
the summer was very unhealthy there it
was very hot it was very uncomfortable
Washington at the time was a very swampy
City it was prone to epidemics during
the summer of malaria and other diseases
there were very bad smells and odors
coming off of the Potomac River and so
they felt it was very unhealthy um so
the doctors agreed to let Garfield go to
the ocean
um the feeling at the time was that the
salt air the bracing ocean wind would
help least was maybe restore his health
at least let him enjoy perhaps the last
few days of his life go back to ghetto
again
you told us about how he bought the
pistol for ten bucks or something and
then you paint a picture again mm-hmm
for those who have been in Washington we
can see this and he would walk down 17th
Street alongside the White House area to
the river for what reason well he had
never owned a gun before and didn't
quite know what to do with it so he
would walk down 17th Street to the river
which at the time there was nothing at
the river it was just a deserted stretch
of waterfront he would take out his gun
and practice shooting you would he would
literally take out this English Bulldog
gun
and put the bullets in and practice
shooting either at a twig or at a bird
or at just the water just to see what it
felt like to have a gun in his hand to
get used to the feeling of the discharge
the smell of the Gunpowder the way the
gun would jolt back at him so that he
would get you
to having it so he'd be comfortable with
it for the two or three weeks that he
was actually stalking the president
which is a frightening thing to think
about in itself he was walking around
with the gun in his pocket most of the
time where else would he have seen the
president with the gun I know you said
he did he go over to the train station
yeah I did that morning that they don't
he went to the train station a couple of
times when when Garfield came back from
the Jersey Shore
he met him at the trailer he he was
there at the train station with his gun
again well so people won't be confused
mm-hmm president and his wife went to
New Jersey she stayed there and the
president came back and so when he came
back he was alone he was alone along
with his two of his sons and Yuto was
there again the tow was there again
watching how would he have known by the
way all these movements back all of this
was in the newspapers all you have to do
is to read the New York Herald or the
Washington star and you would know where
the president was going one other factor
in this thing as you say he would stay
at a place called Riggs and mrs. what
was her name there was a mrs. Grant
there was a there were there a couple of
different boarding houses that he stayed
that the most prominent one was the
Riggs house where he went to at the end
which is the one you mentioned that was
actually a very stylish place in 1880
would you say he didn't have any money
he was shabbily dressed and worn clothes
didn't look well didn't have anymore how
did he pay for these different places
because he kept moving in these during
that time period to these different
houses actually he didn't what he would
do is he'd stay there for a while the
bills would come and he would he would
leave in the middle of the night he
literally did that two or three times
when he went to the Rick's house which
was the most expensive one he did it
literally the night or two before he
shot the president because he knew that
this would be his last chance to shoot
the president he knew that the president
was going to be leaving Washington for a
long extended trip in a few days and he
figured before the bill came he'd be in
jail and no one ever suspected him along
the way of no one ever did worried in
you when you did your research how much
is available on this story and where did
you get your most valuable information
there's a lot available on the story and
I got
most valuable information at the Library
of Congress that's what I did most of
the work on this there were a couple of
very good paper collections the the
Garfield papers the John Sherman papers
the Arthur papers a lot of it was
through newspapers this was a great
period for newspapers every city had a
dozen of them they were the writing was
excellent this story was very heavily
covered for ketosis pacifically he does
there was a small collection of his
papers at Georgetown University where
that's where I got the copy of his
speech and some of his letters but
mostly his criminal trial for murder
went on for three months and during it
he testified for four days and he talked
about everything once he was arrested he
felt no embarrassment no shame at any of
it he felt that he would be a hero and
so he very outwardly talked about
everything he did he dictated a long
autobiography of himself to the New York
Herald that was published he wrote
several long letters and then he
testified for several days so that that
was where the most valuable information
on him came from well what I tried to do
with good toe which I think it's a
little bit different than what other
historians have done is to take him at
his word to not start with the
assumption that he was insane but just
take him at his word and see how we fit
into context why'd you do that
because it struck me that when you take
him and put him into context he oddly
makes sense
I say oddly because the where his logic
led him is a very scary place
he decided in the end that he had to
remove the President of the United
States he decided in the end that that
God was telling him to remove the
President of the United States however
even giving his personal insanity
whether its medical or not it very much
fit in the context of the larger public
debate going on in the country at the
time it was a time when
the the level of partisanship of bad
feelings of personal attacks had reached
such a level that he simply took it one
step further did his trial go on while
President Garfield was still alive no no
they waited until Garfield had died
because for one thing they needed to
know whether it would it would be a
murder charge or an attempted murder
charge the trial started about a month
after he died while we're on it what was
the reason why I mean what in the end
what killed President Garfield
interesting question in fact as part of
Garfield's part of Gautreau's defense
Guto claimed and he had very good
evidence behind him that it was really
did the doctors who killed him Guto SWAT
him but then the doctors examined him
without washing their hands and in the
end Garfield directly died from
infections a combination of infections
and blood poisoning you say that he was
shot twice he was shot twice where one
bullet hit him in the arm and grazed him
the other one hit him flat in the back
and what about the bullets they one of
them was never found the one that raised
him in the arm the one that hit him in
the back this was a question of some
debate they did have ultimately find the
bullet it had formed the body had formed
a sister around the bullet which
ultimately formed an aneurysm later on
during the time those 79 days when
Garfield was was being treated by the
doctors they had no idea where the
bullet was they kept trying to figure it
out at one point they even brought in
Alexander Graham Bell the man who
invented the telephone he had invented a
very crude form of metal detector and
they tried to use it to find the bullet
but the doctors were so far off but
turned out and where they thought it was
that the machine never worked you say
that in the end mmm this may have been
the most successful assassination in
history for what reason
well what --get Oh tried to do was
different than what any other
presidential assassin had tried
what he tried to perform was a regime
change it wasn't simply to kill a person
it wasn't simply to destroy the
president he wanted to replace one
ruling group the Republican half-breeds
led by Garfield and Blaine with a
different ruling group the Republican
stall words led by Arthur and Conkling
and grant that was what he was trying to
do he was able to do it because at the
convention a compromise had been reached
Garfield won the presidential nomination
but as a payback to the stall words to
give them something because they lost
they made Chester Alan Arthur the
stalwart vice president so what Guto was
trying to do was to put Arthur who had
befriended him personally during the
campaign to put him in the White House
and that's very different from any other
presidential assassination and it's a
very frightening thing it's very
different than the way the assassination
is remembered in most history books
there are also three episodes of an
affair but the one I want you to tell
the story before we run out of time is
the Tom Platt story and you have to give
the context of what this is about
okay Tom Platt Tom Platt is a very
interesting person for a lot of reasons
he becomes famous later on he replaces
Conklin later on as the boss of New York
and he's the one who nominates Theodore
Roosevelt to be vice president among the
McKinley ticket in 1900 but back in 1881
he was a minor player compared to Roscoe
Conkling and at the end of this long
fight that Conklin has with Garfield
over who will be the collector of the
Port of New York
Conklin and Platt both resigned from
office on what they consider a point of
principle they know they don't have the
votes and so they resign in a very
visible way and they go back to Albany
New York which is where the state
legislature meets and they insist that
the legislature reinstate them so that
that way their honor will be vindicated
and they could go and fight another day
and by the way that Joseph's Senate
because of 3737 tie yes the Democrats
take control again the Senate shifts
again in the power structure so they go
to Albany the state legislature elect
senators there are now two vacant seats
plaid and Conkling are both running for
re-election this becomes a very
high-profile battle in Albany every day
the Albany legislature the Senate and
the assembly meeting jointly every day
they meet and they they vote on the two
seats about two or three weeks into this
that becomes stalemated it becomes very
very mixed up in bad blood with
accusations and allegations one night a
strange woman walks into the Delavan
House Hotel takes a room no one knows
who she is late that night some kid
who's working there and one of the bad
boys notices tom platt going into her
room he immediately tells one of the one
of Platts political enemies about it
that the half-breeds they walk over to
this room and one of them pulls over a
stepladder and about half a dozen of
them one-by-one climb up the staff
ladder
look over the door through a window
where they see tom platt basically in a
compromising position with the strange
woman
they all look they all immediately go
running off to tell their friends within
an hour about 20 people come over each
one-by-one climbing up the staff ladder
looking in the window to see tom platt
and this woman having their affair
finally after a couple of hours of this
they were having their fun they the
light goes out they pass a note under
the door saying Tom thought we'd give
you ten minutes to walk out and show
yourself he comes out sees the hallway
darkened starts walking down the hallway
and at the first door there's several of
his political enemies looking at him
laughing he ends up that night walking
out of the hotel he instantly becomes a
laugh
stocke all of the newspapers the next
morning rearranged their front pages to
have this this shocking scandal on the
front page when they have a vote the
next the next date about their ballot
for the Senate when Platts name comes up
at their hails of laughter in the new
york state assembly room Platt jumps out
or drops out of the race the next day or
that dead this is the day before the
Garfield assassination Kate chase
Sprague the daughter of Chase who was
who was President Lincoln's Secretary of
the Treasury and later the Supreme Court
justice during the Civil War she was
very much the Belle of Washington a very
very attractive woman very smart and
ambitious she led her father's
presidential campaigns on two or three
occasions so she was very politically
adept she got into a very bad marriage
with a with a senator Sprague of Rhode
Island at the time they were married
during the Civil War he was considered a
catch very handsome very rich it turns
out that he had a drinking problem and
he abused her very badly and it was a
very bad marriage she ends up having an
affair with Roscoe Conkling was one of
the very famous Affairs in Washington
she would go to the Senate gallery watch
Conklin give his speeches and the two of
them were very widely noticed
Conklin was married he left his wife in
Utica and New York and their marriage
was very tense at one point senator
Sprague by then he was governor left
town for a few days
Conkling went up to Rhode Island to
visit mrs. Sprague at their home he came
back well Conkling was there and chased
him off with a shotgun
several newspapers picked up the story
and this became the scandal of the
summer of 77 and the final affair was
James Garfield himself James Garfield
himself Garfield was was very lucky in
life in a lot of ways he had a very good
marriage but early on it was a very
shaky marriage during his first five
years of marriage
- Lucretia Rudolph I was her maiden name
he was off fighting the Civil War and
then he was off on the political stump
and their first five years of marriage I
believe they lived together about 20
weeks the rest of the time he was off
being James Garfield he did have an
affair that she founded found out about
it was with a mrs. Calhoun in New York
City and it almost ended their marriage
early on to their credit James and
Lucretia Garfield stuck it out they
weathered the storm and within a few
years their marriage was a very solid
one it was very young that was one of
the blessings of his life she lived how
long after the assassination she lived
about 35 36 years after the
assassination she died in Southern
California so for people who are
listening to this we have not talked
much about the convention in 1880 the
election itself the campaign and there's
just a lot that we've missed in this how
long did it take you to write this um
the actual churning out of the first
draft took about eight months not
counting the research and the revisions
and how long would have been if you did
put the research in there about a year
and a half and your next book I'm
working now on a book about boss tweet
of New York City our guest has been
Kenneth Ackerman and here is what the
book looks like it's called dark horse
it's all about President James Garfield
and his assassination